The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we're
going to do our last lecture
on scattering in 1D
quantum mechanics,
and we're going to introduce
some powerful ideas,
in particular, the phase
shift and the S matrix,
and they're cool.
We'll use them for good.
Before we get started,
questions from last time?
AUDIENCE: What was the
music that was playing?
PROFESSOR: Just now?
It's a band called
Saint Germain.
It's actually a guy,
but he refers to himself
as a band called Saint Germain.
Anyway, it's from an album
I think called "Traveler."
Physics questions?
Anyone?
OK, good.
Well, bad, actually.
I'd much prefer it
if you had questions,
but I'll take that as a sign
of knowledge, competence,
and mastery.
So last time, we
talked about scattering
past a barrier
with some height L
and some height V, which
I think we called V0,
and we observed a bunch
of nice things about this.
First off, we computed the
probability of transmission
across this barrier as a
function of the energy,
and it had a bunch
of nice features.
First off, it asymptoted
to 1 at high energies,
which makes sense.
Things shouldn't really care if
you have a little tiny barrier.
It went to 0 at 0 energy.
I think we should all
find that obvious.
If you have
extremely low energy,
you're just going to bounce
off this very hard wall.
In between, though,
there's some structure.
In particular, at certain
values of the energy
corresponding to certain
values of the wave
number in the barrier region,
at certain values of the energy,
we saw that the
transmission was perfect.
Oops.
This should have been here.
Sorry.
The transition was perfect at
special values of the energy,
and that the reflection
at those points was 0.
You transmitted perfectly.
But meanwhile, the
reflection, which
is 1 minus the transmission,
hit maxima at special points,
and those special
points turn out
to be half integer shifted
away from the special points
for perfect transmission.
So at certain points, we
have perfect transmission.
At certain points, we have
extremely efficient reflection.
One of our goals
today is going to be
to understand this physics,
the physics of resonance
in scattering off
of a potential.
So the asymptotes we understand.
Classically, that makes sense.
But classically, this is a
really weird structure to see.
And notice that it's also
not something that we
saw when we looked at
scattering off of a simple step.
When we looked at a
simple step, what we got
was something that looked
like 0 and then this.
There was no structure.
It was just a
nice, simple curve.
So something is
happening when we
have a barrier as
opposed to a step.
So our job is going
to be, in some sense,
to answer why are
they so different.
Before we get going, questions
about the step barrier.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That little line that
you drew over your other graph,
is that to scale?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
This one?
AUDIENCE: No, the little line
that you drew right there.
PROFESSOR: This?
Sorry, I should
drawn it separately.
That was the transmission
as a function of energy
across a single step, and
so that looked like this.
AUDIENCE: So if we
were to overlap that
onto our resonance one--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Would
it [INAUDIBLE] to?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
So I just meant to
compare the two.
I just wanted to think of
them as two different systems.
In this system, the transmission
curve is a nice, simple curve.
It has no structure.
In the case of a step barrier,
we get non-zero transmission
at low energies
instead of going to 0
and we get this
resonant structure.
So it's just for contrast.
Before going into
that in detail,
I want to do one slight
variation of this problem.
I'm not going to do any
of the computations.
I'm just going to
tell you how to get
the answer from the answers
we've already computed.
So consider a square well.
You guys have solved
the finite square well
on your problem sets.
Consider a finite square
well again of width L
and of depth now minus V0.
It's the same thing
with V goes to minus V.
And again, I want to
consider scattering states.
So I want to consider states
with positive energy, energy
above the asymptotic potential.
Now, at this point, by now we
all know how to solve this.
We write plain waves
here, plain waves here,
and plain waves in between.
We solve the potential in each
region where it's constant,
and then we impose continuity
of the wave function
and continuity of the
derivative of the wave function
at the matching points.
So we know how to
solve this problem
and deduce the transmission
reflection coefficients.
We've done it for this
problem, and it's exactly
the same algebra.
And in fact, it's so
exactly the same algebra
that we can just take
the results from this one
and take V to minus V and
we'll get the right answer.
You kind of have to.
So if we do, what we get for
the transition probability--
and now this is the transmission
probability for a square well--
and again, I'm going to use the
same dimensionless constants.
g0 squared is equal to 2mL
squared over h bar squared
times V0.
This is 1 over an energy.
This is an energy.
This is dimensionless.
And the dimensionless energy
epsilon is equal to E over V.
To express my
transmission probability,
life is better when
it's dimensionless.
So T, the transmission
probability,
again, it's one of
these horrible 1 overs.
1 over 1 plus 1 over 4
epsilon, epsilon plus 1,
sine squared of g0, square
root of epsilon plus 1.
This is again the same.
You can see what we got last
time by now taking V to minus V
again.
That takes epsilon
to minus epsilon.
So we get epsilon, 1 minus
epsilon, or epsilon minus 1
picking up the minus
sign from this epsilon,
and here we get a 1 minus
epsilon instead of 1
plus epsilon.
That's precisely what
we got last time.
So if you're feeling punchy
at home tonight, check this.
In some sense, you're
going to re-derive it
on the problem set.
So it looks basically
the same as before.
We have a sine
function downstairs,
which again will sometimes be 0.
The sine will
occasionally be 0 when
its argument is
a multiple of pi.
And when that sine
function is 0,
then the transmission
probability is 1 over 1 plus 0.
It's also known as 1.
Transmission is perfect.
So we again get a
resonant structure,
and it's in fact exactly the
same plot, or almost exactly
the same plot.
I'm going to plot
transmission-- let's go ahead
and do this--
transmission probability
as a function, again, of
the dimensionless energy.
And what we get is, again,
not very well drawn resonances
where transmission
goes to 1 thanks
to my beautiful artistic skills.
Points where the reflection
hits a local maximum.
But we know one more
thing about this system,
which is that, in addition to
having scattering states whose
transition probability are
indicated by this plot,
we know we also have, for
negative energy, bound states.
Unlike the step barrier,
for the step well,
we also have bound states.
So here's the
transmission curve,
but I just want to remind
you that we have energies.
At special values of energies,
we also have bound states.
And precisely what
energies depends
on the structure of
the well and the depth,
but if the depth of the well
is, say, V0 so this is minus 1,
we know that the lowest
bound state is always
greater energy than
the bottom of the well.
Cool?
So epsilon, remember,
is E over V0,
and in the square
well of depth V0,
the lowest bound state cannot
possibly have energy lower than
the bottom of the well, so
its epsilon must have epsilon
greater than minus 1.
Anyway, this is
just to remind you
that there are bound states.
Think of this like
a gun put down
on a table in a play in Act One.
It's that dramatic.
It will show up again.
It will come back and
play well with us.
I want to talk about
these resonances.
Let's understand
why they're there.
There are a bunch of
ways of understanding
why these resonances
are present, and let
me just give you a couple.
First, a heuristic
picture, and then I
want to give you a very precise
computational picture of why
these resonances are happening.
So the first is imagine
we have a state where
the transmission is perfect.
What that tells you is
KL is a multiple of pi.
If this is the
distance L of the well,
in here the wave is
exactly one period
if its KL is equal
to a multiple of pi.
Let me simplify my life and
consider the case KL is 2 pi.
Sorry.
4 pi.
I switched notations for you.
I was using in my head, rather
in my notes, width of the well
is 2L for reasons
you'll see on the notes
if you look at the notes,
but let's ignore that.
Let's focus on these guys.
So consider the state,
configuration in energy,
such that in the well, we have
exactly one period of the wave
function.
That means that the value of the
wave function at the two ends
is the same and the
slope is the same.
So whatever the
energy is out here,
if it matches smoothly
and continuously
and its derivative is continuous
here, it will match smoothly
and continuously out here as
well with the same amplitude
and the same period
inside and outside.
The amplitude is the same
and the phase is the same.
That means this wave must
have the same amplitude
and the same period.
It has to have the same period
because it's the same energy,
but it must have the same
amplitude and the same slope
at that point.
And that means
that this wave has
the same amplitude as this wave.
The norm squared is the
transmission probability,
the norm squared of this divided
by the norm squared of this.
That means the transmission
probability has to be 1.
What would have
happened had the system,
instead of being perfectly
periodic inside the well--
actually, let me leave that up.
Let's do it as this.
Shoot.
I'm even getting my qualitative
wave functions wrong.
Let's try this again.
Start at the top,
go down, and then
its deeper inside the well
so the amplitude out here,
the difference in energy between
the energy and the potential,
is less, which means
the period is longer
and the amplitude is greater.
The way I've drawn it, it's
got a particular value.
It's got zero derivative
at this point,
so it's got to-- so
there's our wave function.
Same thing out here.
The important thing
is the amplitude here
has to be the same
as the amplitude
here because the amplitude and
the amplitude and the phase
were exactly as if there had
been no intervening region.
Everyone agree with that?
By contrast, if we had
looked at a situation where
inside the well, it was not the
same amplitude, so for example,
something like this, came
up with some slope which
is different and a value
which is different,
then this is going to match onto
something with the same period
but with a different amplitude
than it would have over here.
Same period because it's
got the same energy,
but a different
amplitude because it
has to match on with the
value and the derivative.
So you can think through
this and pretty quickly
convince yourself of the
necessity of the transmission
aptitude being 1 if this
is exactly periodic.
Again, if this is exactly
one period inside,
you can just
imagine this is gone
and you get a continuous
wave function,
so the amplitude
and the derivative
must be the same
on both sides as
if there was no barrier there.
When the wave function
doesn't have exactly one
period inside the well,
you can't do that,
so the amplitudes can't
be the same on both sides.
But that's not a very
satisfying explanation.
That's really an
explanation about solutions
to the differential equation.
I'm just telling you properties
of second order differential
equations.
Let's think of a
more physical, more
quantum mechanical explanation.
Why are we getting
these resonances?
Well, I want to think
about this in the same way
as we thought about the boxes
in the very first lecture.
Suppose we have
this square well,
and I know I have
some amplitude here.
I've got a wave function.
It's got some amplitude here.
It's got some momentum
going this way,
some positive momentum.
And I want to ask, what's the
probability that I will scatter
past the potential, let's
say to this point right here
just on the other
side of the potential?
What's the probability
that I will scatter across?
Well, you say, we've
done this calculation.
We know the probability to
transmit across this step
potential.
We did that last time.
So that's T step.
We know the probability
of scattering
across this potential step,
and that's transmission up.
And so the probability that
you transmit from here to here
is the probability that you
transmit here first and then
the probability that
you transmit here,
the product of
the probabilities.
Sound reasonable?
Let's vote.
How many people think that this
is equal to the transmission
probability across
the potential well?
Any votes?
You have to vote one
way or the other.
No, it is not.
How many people vote?
OK.
Yes, it is.
The no's have it, and
that's not terribly
surprising because, of course,
these have no resonance
structure, so
where did that come
from if it's just
that thing squared?
So that probably can't be it,
but here's the bigger problem.
Why is this the wrong argument?
AUDIENCE: Because
there's reflection.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
There's reflection, but that's
only one step in the answer
or why it's the wrong answer.
Why else?
AUDIENCE: Your
transmission operations
have to do it far away?
PROFESSOR: That's, true but
I just want the probability,
and if I got here with
positive momentum,
I'm eventually going
to get out to infinity,
so it's the same
probability because it's
just an E to the ikx out here.
The wave function
is just E to the ikx
so the probability is
going to be the same.
Other reasons?
AUDIENCE: Well, the width of
the well is very important,
but the first
argument ignores that.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
That's also true.
So far, the reasons we have are
we need the width of the well,
doesn't appear.
That seems probably wrong.
The second is it's possible
that you could have reflected.
We haven't really
incorporated that
in any sort of elegant way.
AUDIENCE: There are
other ways to transmit
by reflecting twice.
PROFESSOR: That's
absolutely true.
There are other
ways to transmit,
so you could transmit,
then you could reflect.
So we could transmit then
reflect, and reflect again,
and then transmit.
We could transmit,
reflect, reflect, transmit.
What else?
Do probabilities add
in quantum mechanics?
And when you have
products of events,
do probabilities multiply?
What adds in quantum mechanics?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The amplitude.
The wave function.
We do not take the
product of probabilities.
What we do is we ask,
what's the amplitude
to get here from
there, and we take
the amplitude norm squared
to get the probability.
So the correct
question is what's
the amplitude to get
from here to here?
How does the wave
function of the amplitude
change as you move
from here to here?
And for that, think back
to the two slit experiment
or think back to the boxes.
We asked the following question.
The amplitude that you should
transmit across this well
has a bunch of components,
is a sum of a bunch of terms.
You could transmit
down this well.
Inside here, you know
your wave function
is e to the i k prime L-- or
I think I'm calling this k2 x.
And in moving across the
well, your wave function
evolves by an e to the
i k2 L, and then you
could transmit again with
some transmission amplitude.
So this would be the
transmission down times e
to the i k2 L times
the transmit up.
As we saw last time,
these are the same,
but I just want to
keep them separate
so you know which
one talking about.
This is a contribution.
This is something that could
contribute to the amplitude.
Is it the only thing that could
contribute to the amplitude?
No.
What else could contribute?
Bounce, right?
So to get from here, to here
I could transmit, evolve,
transmit.
I could also transmit,
evolve, reflect, evolve,
reflect, evolve, transmit.
So there's also a term
that's t, e to the ikL, r,
e to the minus ikL,
r, e to the iKL.
Sorry, e to the plus
ikL because we're
increasing the
evolution of the phase.
And then transmit
finally at the end.
And these k's are
all k2, but I could
have done that many times.
But notice that each time
what I'm going to do is I'm
going to transmit, reflect,
reflect, transmit or transmit,
reflect, reflect, reflect,
reflect, transmit.
So I'm always going to do
this some number of times.
I do this once, I do this
twice, I do it thrice.
This gives me a
geometric series.
This is t e to
the i k2 L t times
1 plus this quantity plus
this quantity squared.
That's a geometric series,
1 over 1 plus this quantity
squared.
Sorry, 1 minus because
it's a geometric sum.
And what is this quantity?
Well, it's r squared,
and remember the r's
in both directions are
the same, so I'm just
going to write it as
r squared e to the 2i.
r squared.
It's a real number,
but I'm going
to put the absolute
value on anyway.
It's going to simplify my life.
e to the 2i k2 L. So
this is our prediction
from multiple bounces.
What we're doing here is
we're taking seriously
the superposition principle that
says given any process, any way
that that process could happen,
you sum up the amplitudes
and the probability
is the norm squared.
If we have a source
and we have two slits
and I ask you, what's the
probability that you land here,
the probability is not the
sum of the probabilities
for each individual transit.
The probability is the
square of the amplitude where
the amplitude is the
sum, amplitude top
plus amplitude bottom.
Here, there are
many, many slits.
There are many different
ways this could happen.
You could reflect
multiple times.
Everyone cool with that?
By the same token,
we could have done
the same thing for
reflection, but let's stick
with transmission
for the moment.
This is what we get
for the transmission,
and again, the transmission
amplitudes across the step,
as we saw last
time, are the same.
So this is, in fact, t squared.
And this gives us a result for
transmission down the potential
well, and if we use what the
reflection and transmission
amplitudes were
for our step wells,
the answer that this gives is
1 over e to the i k2 L minus 2i
upon the transmission for
a step times sine of k2 L.
Now, this isn't the
same as the probability
that we derived over
here, but that's
because this isn't
the probability.
This was the amplitude.
We just computed
the total amplitude.
To get the probability,
we have to take
the norm squared
of the amplitude.
And when we take
the norm squared,
what we get is 1 upon 1 plus 1
over 4 epsilon, epsilon plus 1,
sine squared of g0
root epsilon plus 1.
We get the same answer.
AUDIENCE: Is that an equality?
PROFESSOR: This is an equality.
Oh, sorry.
Thank you, Barton.
We get to the
transmission probability
when we take the norm
squared of the amplitude.
Thank you.
Is equal to this, which is
the same as we got before.
Thanks.
Yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: Tell me why kL
equals pi doesn't work.
PROFESSOR: kL equals
pi doesn't work.
It does.
You just have to be
careful what kL--
AUDIENCE: On the
first drawing, you
changed your kL [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because I'm an idiot.
Because I got a
factor of 2 wrong.
Thank you.
Thank you, Matt.
Answer analysis.
It's a wonderful thing.
This does something
really nice for us.
Why are we getting a
resonance at special values
at the energy?
What's happening?
Well, in this quantum
mechanical process
of multiple interactions,
multiple scatterings,
there are many terms in the
amplitude for transmitting.
There are terms that
involve no reflection,
there are terms that
involve two reflections,
involve four reflections,
and they all come with an
actual magnitude and a phase.
And when the phase is the
same, they add constructively,
and when the phases are not
the same, they interfere.
And when the phases
are exactly off,
they interfere
destructively, and that
is why you're
getting a resonance.
Multiple terms in
your superposition
interfere with each
other, something
that does not
happen classically.
Classically, the
probabilities are products.
Quantum mechanically,
we have superposition
and probabilities are the
squares of the amplitude,
and we get interference
effects in the probabilities.
Cool?
To me, this is a nice, glorious
version of the two slit
experiment, and we're going
to bump up again into it later
when we talk about the physics
of solids in the real world.
Questions at this point?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Question on
something you said earlier.
What is the k2 L
equals [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, what's
special about that?
What's special about that is at
this point, where kL is n pi,
we get perfect transmission.
When kL is equal
to n plus 1/2 pi,
the reflection is
as good as it gets.
What that's really
doing is it's saying,
when is this locally largest?
So that's the special
points when the transmission
is as small as possible, which
means the reflection, which
is 1 minus the
transmission probability,
is as large as possible.
And you can get that, again,
from these expressions.
Other questions?
So I want to think a little more
about these square barriers.
And in particular, in
thinking about the square well
barrier, what we've
been talking about
all along are
monochromatic wave packets.
We've been talking about
plain waves, just simply
e to the ikx, but you
can't put a single particle
in a state which
is a plain wave.
It's not normalizable.
What we really mean
at the end of the day
when we talk about
single particles is we
put them in some well localized
wave packet, which at time 0,
let's say, is at position x0,
which in this case is negative,
and which has some well
defined average momentum, k0.
I'll say it's the expectation
value of momentum in this wave
packet.
And the question we
really want to ask
when we talk about scattering
is, what happens to this beast
as it hits the
barrier, which I'm
going to put the
left hand side at 0
and the right hand
side at L and let
the depth be minus v0 again.
What happens as this incident
wave packet hits the barrier
and then scatters off?
Well, we know what would
happen if it was a plain wave,
but a plain wave
wouldn't be localized.
So this is the
question I want to ask,
and I want to use the
results that we already have.
Now, here's the key thing.
Consider to begin
with just a wave
packet for a free
particle centered
at x0 and with momentum k0,
just look for a free particle.
We know how to write this.
We can put the
system, for example,
we can take our wave
function at time 0
to be a Gaussian, some
normalization times
e to the minus x minus x0
squared over 2a squared.
And we want to give
it some momentum k0,
and you know how to do that
after the last problem set,
e to the i k0 x.
Everyone cool with that?
So there's our
initial wave function,
and we want to know how
it evolves with time,
and we know how to do that.
To evolve it in time,
we first expand it
in energy eigenstates.
So psi of x0 is equal to--
well, the energy eigenstates
in this case are plain waves,
dk e to the ikx over root 2 pi
times some coefficients, f of
k, the expansion coefficients.
But these are just
the Fourier transform
of our initial
Gaussian wave packet,
and we know what the form
of f of k is equal to.
Well, it's a Gaussian
of width 1 upon alpha
e to the minus k minus k0
because it has momentum k0,
so it's centered around k0,
squared over 2 times a squared,
and the a goes upstairs.
And the position of
the initial wave packet
is encoded in the
Fourier transform,
and I'm going to put
a normalization here,
which I'm not going to worry
about, with an overall phase
e to the minus ik x0.
So in just the same say
that adding on a phase,
e to the i k0 x, in
the position space
wave function tells you what the
expectation value of momentum
is, tacking on the phase--
and we can get this
from just Fourier transform--
tacking on the phase
e to the ik x0 in
the Fourier transform
tells you the center point,
the central position,
of the wave packet.
So this you did on
the problem set,
and this is a trivial
momentum space
version of the same thing.
So here's our wave
packet expanded
in plain waves, which
are energy eigenstates.
And the statement that
these are energy eigenstates
is equivalent to the statement
that under time evolution,
they do nothing but
rotate by a phase.
So if we want to know
what the wave function is
as a function of time, psi of x
and t is equal to the integral,
dk, the Fourier mode f of k.
I'll write it out.
Actually, I'm going to
write this out explicitly.
f of k 1 over root
2 pi e to the ikx
minus omega t where omega, of
course, is a function of t.
It's a free particle, so
for our free particle,
h bar squared k squared upon
2m is equal to h bar omega.
We've done this before.
But now what I want to do
is I want to take exactly
the same system and I
want to add, at position
zero, a well of
depth v0 and width L.
How is our story
going to change?
Well, we want our initial
wave packet, which is up to us
to choose, we want our initial
wave packet to be the same.
We want to start
with a Gaussian far,
far, far away from the barrier.
We want it to be well
localized in position
and well localized in momentum
space, not perfectly localized,
of course.
It's a finite Gaussian to
satisfy the uncertainty
principle, but it's
well localized.
So how does this story change?
Well, this doesn't
change at all.
It's the same wave function.
However, when we expand
in energy eigenstates,
the energy eigenstates are
no longer simple plain waves.
The energy eigenstates,
as we know for the system,
take a different form.
For the square well and positive
energy scattering states,
the plain wave, or the
energy eigenstates,
which I will label by k, just
because I'm going to call e
is equal to h bar squared
k squared upon 2m--
the energy is a constant-- which
is the k asymptotically far
away from the potential.
The wave function I can write
as 1 over root 2 pi times
e to the ikx when we're
on the left hand side,
but being on the left hand side
is equivalent to multiplying
by a theta function of minus x.
This is the function which is
0 when its argument is negative
and 1 when its
argument is positive.
Plus we have the
reflected term, which
has an amplitude, r, which
is again a function of k.
This is the
reflection amplitude,
also known as c upon a.
e to the minus ikx-- again,
on the left hand side--
theta of minus x plus a
transition amplitude whose
norm squared is transmission
probability e to the ikx when
we're on the right, theta of x.
So this is just a slightly
different notation
than what we usually write
with left and right separated.
So what we want to do now is
we want to decompose our wave
function in terms of the
actual energy eigenstates.
The way we're going to do that,
and having done that, having
expanded our wave
function in this basis,
we can determine the time
evolution in the following way.
First, we expand
the wave function
at time 0 as an
integral, dk, and I'm
going to pull the root 2 pi out.
And we have some
Fourier transform,
which I'm now going
to call f tilde
because is slightly different
than the f we used before,
but it's what the expansion
coefficients have to be,
f tilde of k times
this beast, phi of k.
Let me actually
take this product
and write it out in
terms of the three terms.
So those three terms are going
to be f of k, again tilde,
e to the ikx, theta of minus x,
plus f tilde r e to the minus
ikx, theta of minus
x plus f tilde t
e to the ikx, theta of x.
Let's look at these terms.
Finally, we want to look
at the time evolution,
but we started out as a
superposition of states
with definite
energy labeled by k,
so we know the time evolution
is e to the ikx minus omega t, e
to the i minus ikx plus
omega t, so minus omega t,
and kx minus omega t.
So we can immediately, from this
time evolving wave function,
identify these
two terms as terms
with a central peak
moving to the right,
and this, central peak moving
to the left, kx plus omega t.
Everyone cool with that?
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain real quick
one more time how
that's the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How that--
sorry, say again.
AUDIENCE: How the top
equation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How the top
equation led to this,
or just where this came from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
This is just a notational thing.
Usually when I say phi sub
k is equal to, on the left,
e to the ikx with some
overall amplitude.
Let's say 1 over
2 pi e to the ikx
plus c over a e to the
minus ikx on the left,
and because this is
the reflected wave,
I'm just going to call this
R. And then on the right,
we have e to the ikx.
There's only a wave
travelling to the right
and the coefficient is the
transmission amplitude.
So this is what we normally
write, but then I'm
using the so-called
theta function.
Theta of x is defined as 0
when x is less than 0 and 1
when x is greater than 0.
This is a function 1.
Using theta function
allows me to write
this thing as a single
function without having
to goose around
with lots of terms.
Is that cool?
Great.
AUDIENCE: Are we just
thinking about one
step here or the whole
well, because always, we
should have something
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
Excellent, excellent.
Thank you so much.
What I want to do is I want
to think of the wave function.
This is a good description when
the particle is far, far away,
and this is a good description
when the particle is not
in the potential.
Sorry.
Thank you.
I totally glossed
over this step.
I want to imagine
this as a potential
where all of the matching is
implemented at x equals 0,
so when I write it
in this fashion.
Another equivalent way
to think about this
is this is a good description
of the wave function
when we're not inside the well.
So for the purposes of the
rest of the analysis that I'm
going to do, this
is exactly what
the form of the wave function is
when we're not inside the well,
and then let's just
not use this to ask
about questions inside the well.
When I write it in
this theta form,
or for that matter, when
I write it in this form,
this is not the form.
What I mean is left of the
well and right of the well,
and inside-- t e to
the ikx-- inside,
it's doing something
else, but we
don't want to ask
questions about it.
That's just going
to simplify my life.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And is
the lowercase t then
just the square
root of capital T?
PROFESSOR: It's the
square root of capital T
but you've got to be careful
because there can be a phase.
Remember, this is the
amplitude, and what it really
is is this reflection
is B over A,
and these guys are
complex numbers.
And it's true that B
over A norm squared
is the transmission
probability, but B over A
has a phase, and that
quantity I'm going to call t,
and we'll interpret that in
more detail in a few minutes.
So it's of this form.
I just want to look at
each of these three terms.
In particular, I want to
focus on them at time 0.
So at t equals 0, what
does this look like?
Well, that first term
is integral dk of f of k
e to the ikx minus omega
t, theta of minus x.
Notice that theta of minus
x is independent of k.
It's independent
of the integral,
so this is just a function
times theta of minus x.
And this function
was constructed
to give us the initial Gaussian.
And this was at t equals 0.
So this is just our Gaussian
at position x0 centered
around value k0 at time
equals 0, theta of minus x.
Sorry, at position x0.
All this function is, this
is the Fourier transform
of our Gaussian and we're
undoing the Fourier transform.
This is just giving
us our Gaussian back.
And as long as the particle
is far away from the well--
so here's the well and
here's our wave packet--
that theta function
is totally irrelevant
because the Gaussian makes
it 0 away from the center
of the Gaussian anyway.
And so just as a
quick question, if we
look at this is a function of
t so we put back in the minus
omega t, so if we put back
in the time dependence,
this is a wave that's
moving to the right,
and to be more
precise about that,
what does it mean to say it's
a wave moving to the right?
Well, this is an envelope
on this set of plain waves,
and the envelope,
by construction,
was well localized
around position x
but it was also well
localized in momentum,
and in particular,
the Fourier transform
is well localized
around the momentum k0.
And so using the method
of stationary phase,
or just asking, where is the
phase constant stationary,
we get that the central
peak of the wave function
satisfies the equation d d k0.
If you're not familiar
with stationary phase,
let the recitation
instructors know
and they will
discuss it for you.
The points of stationary
phase of this superposition
of this wave packet lie
at the position d dk of kx
minus omega of kt
evaluated at the peak, k0,
of the distribution.
But d dk of kx minus omega
t is, for the first term x,
and for the second
term, d dk of omega.
Well, we know that omega, we're
in the free particle regime.
Omega, we all know what it is.
It's h bar k squared upon 2m.
We take the derivative
with respect to k.
We get h bar k over m.
The 2's cancel, so x
minus h bar k over m t.
And a place where
this phase is 0,
where the phase is
stationary, moves over time
as x is equal to
h bar k over m t.
But h bar k over m,
that's the momentum.
p over m, that's the
classical velocity.
So this is v0 t, the velocity
associated with that momentum.
So this is good.
We've done the right job of
setting up our wave packet.
We built a Gaussian
that was far away that
was moving in with a fixed
velocity towards the barrier,
and now we want to know what
happens after it collides off
the barrier.
Cool?
So what we really want
to ask is at late times,
what does the wave
function look like?
Again, we're focusing
on the first term.
The position of this wave packet
at late times, a positive t,
is positive, and
when it's positive,
then this theta function
kills its contribution
to the overall wave function.
This theta is now theta
of minus a positive number
and this Gaussian is gone.
What is it replaced by?
Well, these two terms
aren't necessarily 0.
In particular, this one
is moving to the left.
So as time goes forward, x
is moving further and further
to the left, and so this theta
function starts turning on.
And similarly, as
x goes positive,
this theta function
starts turning on as well.
Let's focus on this third
term, the transmitted term.
Let's focus on this third term.
In particular, that term looks
like integral dk over root 2
pi, f times the transmission
amplitude times e
to the ikx minus omega t.
And there's an overall
theta of x outside,
but for late times where
the center of the wave
packet where the transmitted
wave packet should be positive,
this theta is just going to be
1 so we can safely ignore it.
It's just saying we're
far off to the right.
And now I want to
do one last thing.
This was an overall envelope.
This t was our
scattering amplitude,
and I want to write it
in the following form.
I want to write it as root
T e to the minus i phi
where phi is k.
So what this is
saying is that indeed,
as was pointed out
earlier, the norm squared
of this coefficient T is the
transmission probability,
but it has a phase.
And what I want to know is
what does this phase mean?
What information is
contained in this phase?
And that's what
we're about to find.
So let's put that in.
Here we have root
T and minus phi
where omega and phi
are both functions of k
because the
transmission amplitudes
depend on the momentum,
or the energy.
And now I again want to know,
how does this wave packet move?
If I look at this wave packet,
how does it move en masse?
As a group of waves, how
does this wave packet move?
In particular,
with what velocity?
I'll again make an argument
by stationary phase.
I'll look at a point
of phase equals 0
and ask how it moves over time.
And the point of
stationary phase
is again given by d dk of
the phase kx minus omega
of kt minus phi of k is equal
to 0 evaluated at k0, which
is where our envelope
is sharply peaked.
This expression
is equal to-- this
is, again, x minus d omega dk.
That's the classical velocity,
v0 t-- minus d phi dk.
But just as a note, d phi
dk is equal to d omega dk,
d phi d omega, but
this is equal to-- this
is just the chain rule.
d omega dk, that's
the classical velocity.
d phi d omega, that's
d phi dE times h bar.
I just multiplied by h
bar on the top and bottom.
So this is equal to x minus
v0 t plus h bar d phi dE.
So first off, let's just make
sure that the units make sense.
That's a length,
that's a velocity,
so this had better
have units of time.
Time, that's good.
So h bar times d phase over dE.
Well, phase is dimensionless,
energy is units of energy,
h is energy times time, so
this dimensionally works out.
So this is 0.
So the claim is the
point of stationary phase
has this derivative equal to
0, so setting this equal to 0
tells us that the peak
of the wave function
moves according
to this equation.
So this is really satisfying.
This should be really satisfying
for a couple of reasons.
First off, it tells you that
the peak of the transmitted wave
packet, not just a plain wave,
the peak of the actual wave
packet, well localized,
moves with overall velocity
v0, the constant velocity
that we started with,
and that's good.
If it was moving with
some other velocity,
we would have lost
energy somehow.
That would be not so sensible.
So this wave packet is moving
with an overall velocity v0.
However, it doesn't
move along just
as the original wave
packet's peak had.
It moves as if shifted in time.
So the phase, and more to
the point, the gradient
of the phase with
respect to energy,
the rate of change with energy
of the phase times h bar
is giving us a shift in the time
of where the wave packet is.
What does that mean?
Let's be precise about this.
Let's interpret this.
Here's the interpretation
I want to give you.
Consider classically the system.
Classically, we have an
object with some energy,
and it rolls along and it finds
a potential well, and what
happens when it gets
into the potential well?
It speeds up.
because it's got
a lot more energy
relative to the potential.
So it goes much faster in here
and it gets to the other side
and it slows down again.
So if I had taken a
particle with velocity--
let's call this
position 0 and let's
say it gets to this
wall at time 0,
so it's moving with
x is equal to v0 t,
if there had been
no barrier there,
then at subsequent times,
it would get out here
in a time that distance
over v0, right?
However, imagine this well
was extraordinarily deep.
If this well were
extraordinarily deep,
what would happen?
Well basically, in here, its
velocity is arbitrarily large,
and it would just immediately
jump across this well.
This would be a perfectly
good description of the motion
before it gets to the well,
but after it leaves the well,
the position is going
to be v0 t plus-- well,
what's the time shift?
The time shift is
the time that we
didn't need to cross this gap.
And how much would
that time have been?
Well, it's the distance
divided by the velocity.
That's the time we didn't need.
So t plus-- it moves as
if it's at a later time--
t plus L over v0.
Cool?
So if we had a really deep
well and we watched a particle,
we would watch it move x0,
x v0 t, v0 t, v0 t, v0 t
plus L over v, v0
t plus L over v.
So it's the time that we made
up by being deep in the well.
So there's a classical picture
because it goes faster inside.
So comparing these, here
we've done a calculation
of the time shift due
to the quantum particle
quantum mechanically
transiting the potential well.
So let's compare these.
This says the classical
prediction is the time it took,
delta t, classical is
equal to L over v0,
and the question is,
is this the same?
One way to phrase this question
is, is it the same as h bar d
phi dE evaluated at k0?
From our results last time,
for the amplitude c over a,
we get that phi is equal
to-- which is just minus
the argument, or the phase, of
c over a, or of the transmission
amplitude little
t-- phi turns out
to be equal to k2 L minus arctan
of k1 squared plus k2 squared
over 2 k1 k2, tan of
k2 L. I look at this
and it doesn't tell
me all that much.
It's a little bit bewildering,
so let's unpack this.
What we really
want to know is, is
this close to the
classical result?
Here's a quick way to check.
We know this expression is
going to simplify near resonance
where the sine vanishes,
so let's look, just
for simplicity,
near the resonance.
And in particular, let's
look near the resonance k2 L
is equal to n pi.
Then it turns out that a
quick calculation gives you
that h bar d phi dE
at this value of k,
at that value of the energy,
goes as L over 2 v0 times
1 plus the energy over
the depth of the well, v0.
Now remember, the classical
approximation was L over v0.
We just did this very quickly.
We did it assuming an
arbitrarily deep well.
So v0 is arbitrarily
larger in magnitude than E,
so this term is negligible.
Where we should compare
that very simple, naive
classical result is
here, L over 2 v0.
And what we see is that the
quantum mechanical result
gives a time shift which
is down by a factor of 2.
So what's going on?
Well, apparently, the
things slow down inside.
The time that it
took us to cross
was greater than you
would have naively guessed
by making it arbitrarily deep.
And we can make that
a little more sharp
by plotting, as a function of
E over v0, the actual phase
shift.
If do a better job than
saying it's infinitely deep,
the classical prediction
looks something like this,
and this is for delta t,
the time shift, classical.
When you look at the correct
quantum mechanical result,
here's what you find,
where the difference is
a factor of 2, 1/2 the
height down, and again,
1/2 the height down.
So this is that factor
of 2 downstairs.
So the wave packet goes
actually a little bit faster
than the classical
prediction would
guess except near
resonance, and these
are at the resonant
values of the momentum.
At the resonant values
of the momentum,
it takes much longer
to get across.
Instead of going a
little bit faster
than the classical
result, it goes a factor
of 2 slower than the
classical result.
And so now I ask
you the question,
why is it going more slowly?
Why does it spend so much more
time inside the well quantum
mechanically than it
would have classically?
Why is the particle effectively
taking so much longer
to transit the well
near resonance?
AUDIENCE: Because it can
reflect and it can keep going
and a classical particle
is not going to do that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So the classical particle
just goes across.
The quantum mechanical
particle has a superposition
of contributions
to its amplitude
where it transits-- transit,
bounce, bounce, transit,
transit, bounce, bounce,
bounce, bounce, transit.
And now you can
ask, how much time
was spent by each of those
imaginary particles imaginarily
moving across?
And if you're careful about
how you set up that question,
you can recover this factor of
2, which is kind of beautiful.
But the important thing here is
when you're hitting resonance,
the multiple scattering
processes are important.
They're not canceling out.
They're not at random phase.
They're not interfering
destructively with each other.
They're interfering
constructively,
and you get perfect
transmission precisely
because of the
constructive interference
of an infinite number
of contributions
to the quantum
mechanical amplitude.
And this is, again, we're
seeing the same thing
in this annoying slow down.
This tells us another
thing, though,
which is that the
scattering phase, the phase
in the transmission
amplitude, contains
an awful lot of the
physics of the system.
It's telling us about how long
it takes for the wave packet
to transit across the
potential, effectively.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the
vertical axis being used for?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
The vertical axis
here is the shift
in the time due to the fact
that it went across this well
and went a little
bit faster inside.
So empirically, what it means is
when you get out very far away
and you watch the motion
of the wave packet,
and you ask, how long
has it been since it got
to the barrier in
the first place,
it took less time than
you would have guessed
by knowing that its velocity is
v0, and the amount of time less
is this much time.
That answer your question?
Good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is each
of the amplitudes 1/2?
Why is the first one, and
it bounces around twice.
PROFESSOR: When we compare
the classical amplitude
and the limit that
v0 goes to infinity?
The comparison is
just a factor of 2.
It's more complicated out here.
In the limit that v0 is
large, this is exactly 1/2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The
resonances are leading
to this extra factor of 1/2.
I have to say I don't
remember exactly
whether, as you include
the sub-leading terms of 1
over v0, whether it stays
1/2 or whether it doesn't,
but in the limit
that v0 is large,
it remains either close
to 1/2 or exactly 1/2,
I just don't remember exactly.
The important thing is
that there's a sharp dip.
It takes much longer to transit,
and so you get less bonus time,
as it were.
You've gained less time in
the quantum mechanical model
than the classical model.
And when you do the experiment,
you get the quantum result.
That's the crucial point.
Other questions?
So the phase contains an
awful lot of the physics.
So I want to generalize
this whole story
in a very particular way,
this way of reorganizing
the scattering in 1D.
What we're doing
right now is we're
studying scattering
problems in one dimension,
but we live in three dimensions.
The story is going to be
more complicated in three
dimensions.
It's going to be more
complicated in two dimensions,
but the basic ideas
are all the same.
It's just the details are
going to be different.
And one thing that turns out
to be very useful in organizing
scattering, both
in one dimension
and in three
dimensions, is something
called the scattering matrix.
I'm going to talk
about that now.
In three dimensions,
it's essential,
but even in one dimension,
where it's usually not used,
it's a very powerful
way to organize
our knowledge of the system as
encoded by the scattering data.
So here's the basic idea.
As we discussed
before, what we really
want to do in the ideal world
is take some unknown potential
in some bounded
region, some region,
and outside, we have the
potential is constant.
[INAUDIBLE] my bad
artistic skills.
So potential is
constant out here.
And the potential could be
some horrible thing in here
that we don't happen
to know, and we
want to read off of
the scattering process,
we want to be able to deduce
something about the potential.
So for example, we
can deduce the energy
by looking at the
position of the barriers,
and we can disentangle
the position of the energy
and the depth and the width
by looking at the phase shift,
by looking at the time delay.
So we can deduce all the
parameters of our potential
by looking at the resonance
points and the phase shift.
I want to do this more
generally for general potential.
And to set that
up, we need to be
a bit more general
than we've been.
So in general, if we
solve this potential,
as we talked about before, we
have A and B, e to the ikx,
e to the minus ikx out
here, and out here, we
have C e to the ikx and
D e to the minus ikx.
And I'm not going to
ask what happens inside.
Now we can do, as
discussed, two kinds
of scattering experiments.
We can send things in from
the left, in which case
A is nonzero, and then things
can either transmit or reflect,
but nothing's going to come
in from infinity, so D is 0.
Or we can do the
same in reverse.
Send things in from here,
and that corresponds to A
is 0, nothing coming in
this way but d0 and 0.
And more generally, we can
ask the following question.
Suppose I send some amount
of stuff in from the left
and I send some amount of stuff
in from the right, D. Then
that will tell me how much stuff
will be going out to the right
and how much stuff will
be going out to the left.
If you tell me how
much is coming in,
I will tell you how much
is coming out, B, C.
So if you could
solve this problem,
the answer is just some
paralinear relations
between these, and we can write
this as a matrix, which I will
S11, S12, S21, S22.
What this matrix is doing is
it takes the amplitude you're
sending in from
the left to right
and tells you the amplitude
coming out to the left
or to the right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do we know
this relation is linear?
PROFESSOR: If you double the
amount of stuff coming in,
then you must double the
amount of stuff going out
or probability is not conserved.
Also, we've derived
these relations.
You know how the relations work.
The relations work by satisfying
a series of linear equations
between the various
coefficients such
that you have continuity
and differentiability at all
the matching points.
But the crucial
thing of linearity
is probability is conserved
and time evolution is linear.
Other questions?
So this is just some stupid
matrix, and we call it,
not surprisingly, the S
matrix in all of its majesty.
The basic idea is this.
For scattering problems, if
someone tells you the S matrix,
and in particular,
if someone tells you
how all the coefficients of
the S matrix vary with energy,
then you've completely solved
any scattering problem.
You tell me what A and D are.
Great.
I'll tell you exactly what
B and C are mode by mode,
and I can do this
for superposition.
So this allows you to completely
solve any scattering problem
in quantum mechanics
once you know it.
So it suffices to know S to
solve all scattering problems.
I want to now spend just a
little bit of time thinking
about what properties the
S matrix and its components
must satisfy.
What properties
must the S matrix
satisfy in order to
jibe well with the rest
of the rules of
quantum mechanics?
I'm not going to study
any particular system.
I just want to ask
general questions.
So the first thing
that must be true
is that stuff doesn't disappear.
Disapparate is probably
the appropriate.
Stuff doesn't leak
out of the world,
so whatever goes
in must come out.
What that means is norm of
A squared plus norm of D
squared, which is the
probability density in
and probability
density out, must
be equal to B squared
plus C squared.
Everyone agree with that?
AUDIENCE: Why can't stuff
stay in the potential?
PROFESSOR: Why can't stuff
That's a good.
So if we're looking at
fixed energy eigenstates,
we know that we're in
a stationary state,
so whatever the amplitude
going into the middle is,
it must also be coming
out of the middle.
There's another way
to say this, which
is let's think about it not
in terms of individual energy
eigenstates.
Let's think about it in
terms of wave packets.
So if we take a
wave packet of stuff
and we send in that wave packet,
it has some momentum, right?
This is going to get
delicate and technical.
Let me just stick with
the first statement, which
is that if stuff
is going in, then
it has to also be
coming out by the fact
that this is an
energy eigenstate.
The overall probability
distribution
is not changing in time.
If stuff went in and
it didn't come out,
that would mean
it's staying there.
That would mean
that the probability
density is changing in time.
That's not what happens
in an energy eigenstate.
The probability distribution
is time independent.
Everyone cool with that?
So let's think, though,
about what this is.
I can write this in
the following nice way.
I can write this as A
complex conjugate D complex
conjugate, AD.
And on the right
hand side, this is
equal to B complex conjugate,
C complex conjugate, BC.
I have done nothing
other than write this out
in some suggested form.
But B and C are equal
to the S matrix,
so BC is the S matrix times
A, and B complex conjugate,
C complex conjugate is the
transposed complex conjugate.
So this is equal to A complex
conjugate, D complex conjugate,
S transpose complex conjugate,
also known as adjoint,
and this is S on AD.
Yeah?
But this has to be equal
to this for any A and D.
So what must be true of
S dagger S as a matrix?
It's got to be the identity
as a matrix in order for this
to be true for all A and D. Ah.
That's cool.
Stuff doesn't disappear.
S is a unitary matrix.
So S is a unitary matrix.
Its inverse is its adjoint.
You'll study this in a little
more detail on the problem set.
You studied the
definition of unitary
on the last problem set.
So that's the
first thing about S
and it turns out to
be completely general.
Anytime, whether you're in one
dimension or two dimensions
or three, if you send stuff
in, it should not get stuck.
It should come out.
And when it does come
out, the statement
that it comes out for
energy eigenstates
is the statement that
S is a unitary matrix.
Questions on that.
So a consequence of that is
that the eigenvalues of S
are phases, pure phases.
So I can write S--
I'll write them
as S1 is equal to
e to the i of phi 1
and S2 is equal
to the i of phi 2.
So the statement that
S is a unitary matrix
leads to constraints
on the coefficients,
and you're going to derive
these on your problem set.
I'm just going to list them now.
The first is that
the magnitude of S11
is equal to the
magnitude of S22.
The magnitude of S12 is equal
to the magnitude of S21.
More importantly, S12 norm
squared plus S11 squared
is equal to 1.
And finally, S11, S12 complex
conjugate, plus S21, S22
complex conjugate is equal to 0.
So what do these mean?
What are these
conditions telling us?
They're telling us,
of course, they're
a consequence of
conservational probability,
but they have another meaning.
To get that other
meaning, let's look
at the definition of the
transmission amplitudes.
In particular, consider
the case that we send stuff
in from the left and
nothing in from the right.
That corresponds to D equals 0.
When D equals 0, what
does this tell us?
It tells us that B
is equal to-- and A
equals 1 for normalization.
B is equal to-- well, D is
equal to 0, so it's just S11 A,
so B over A is S11.
And similarly, C over A is S21.
But C over A is the
thing that we've
been calling the transmission
amplitude, little t,
and this is the reflection
amplitude, little r.
So this is the reflection
amplitude, if we send in stuff
and it bounces off,
reflects to the left,
and this is the transmission
amplitude for transmitting
to the right.
Everyone cool with that?
This is reflection
to the left, this
is transmission to the right.
By the same token, this is
going to be transmission
to the left and
reflection to the right.
So now let's look
at these conditions.
S11 is reflection and this
is going to be reflection.
This says that the
reflection to the left
is equal to the reflection
to the right in magnitude.
Before, what we saw was
for the simple step,
the reflection amplitude was
equal from left to right, not
just the magnitude,
but the actual value
was equal from the
left and the right.
It was a little bit of a
cheat because they were real.
And we saw that that
was a consequence
of just being the step.
We didn't know
anything more about it.
But now we see that
on general grounds,
on conservation of
probability grounds,
the magnitude of the
reflection to the left
and to the right for any
potential had better be equal.
And similarly, the magnitude of
the transmission for the left
and the transmission to the
right had better be equal,
all other things being-- if
you're sending in from the left
and then transmitting
to the left,
or sending in from the right
and transmitting to the right.
And what does this one tell us?
Well, S12 and S11, that tells
us that little t squared, which
is the total probability to
transmit, plus little r squared
is the total probability
to reflect, is equal to 1,
and we saw this last time, too.
This was the earlier definition
of nothing gets stuck.
And this one you'll study
on your problem set.
It's a little more subtle.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain one
more time why is S unitary?
How did you get that?
PROFESSOR: So the way we got
S was unitary is first off,
this is just the
definition of S. S
is the matrix that,
for any energy,
relates A and D, the
ingoing amplitudes,
to the outgoing amplitudes B
and C. Just the definition.
Meanwhile, I claim that
stuff doesn't go away,
nothing gets stuck,
nothing disappears,
so the total probability
density of stuff going in
must be equal to the
total probability
density of stuff going out.
The probability
of stuff going in
can be expressed as this
row vector times this column
vector, and on the out, this
vector, and then we use the
definition of the S matrix.
This column vector is equal
to S times this row vector.
BC is equal to S times AD.
And when we take the
transposed complex conjugate,
I get AD transposed
complex conjugate,
S transposed complex conjugate,
but that's the S adjoint.
But in order for this to be
true for any vectors A and D,
it must be that S dagger S
is unitary is the identity,
but that's the definition
of a unitary matrix.
Cool?
Others.
You're going to prove
a variety of things
on the problem set
about the scattering
matrix and its
coefficients, but I
want to show you two
properties of it.
The first is reasonably
tame, and it'll
make a little sharper the
step result we got earlier
that the reflection in both
directions off the step
potential was in fact
exactly the same.
Suppose our system is
time reversal invariant.
So if t goes to minus
t, nothing changes.
This would not be
true, for example,
if we had electric
currents in our system
because as we take t to minus
t, then the current reverses.
So if the current shows
up in the potential,
or if a magnetic
field due to a current
shows up in the
potential energy,
then as we change
t to minus t, we
change the direction
of the current,
we change the direction
of the magnetic field.
In simple systems where we
have time reversal invariance,
for example,
electrostatics, but not,
for example, magnetostatics,
suppose we have time reversal
invariance, then what you've
shown on a previous problem
set is that psi is a
solution, then psi star,
psi complex conjugate
is also a solution.
And using these, what you'll
see what you can show--
and I'm not going to
go through the steps
for this-- well, that's easy.
If we do the time reversal,
the wave function,
looking on the left or on the
right, so comparing these guys,
what changes?
Under time reversal,
we get a solution.
Given this solution, we
have another solution,
A star e to the minus ikx,
B star e to the plus ikx.
Minus star, star, plus.
So we can run
exactly the same game
but now with this amplitude.
And when you put the
conditions together,
which you'll do on the problem
set, another way to say this
is the same solution with k
to minus k and with A and B
replaced by their
complex conjugates
and C and D replaced by each
other's complex conjugates.
Then this implies
that it must be true
that A and D, which are now
the outgoing guys because we've
time reversed, is equal
to S-- and I'll write this
out explicitly-- S11, S12,
S21, S22, B star, and C star.
So these together give you that.
Therefore, S complex
conjugate S is equal to 1.
If S complex conjugate
S is equal to 1,
then S inverse is
equal to S transpose,
just putting this on the right.
So S transpose is equal to S
inverse is equal to S adjoint
because S is also unitary.
So time reversal invariance
implies, for example,
that S dagger is
equal to S star,
or S equal to S transpose.
This is what I
wanted to write here.
Gives us that S is
equal to S transpose.
And in particular, this tells
us that S21 is equal to S12.
The off diagonal
terms are equal,
not just in magnitude, which
was insured by unitary,
but if, in addition to
being a unitary system,
which of course, it should
be, if in addition it's
time reversal invariant, then we
see that the off diagonal terms
are equal not just in
magnitude but also in phase.
And as you know, the
phase is important.
The phase contains physics.
It tells you about time delays
and shifts in the scattering
process.
So the phases are the same.
That statement is
not a trivial one.
It contains physics.
So when the system is time
reversal invariant, the phases
as well as the
amplitudes are the same.
And you'll derive a series
of related conditions
or consequences for the S
matrix from various properties
of the system, for
example, parity,
if you could have a
symmetric potential.
But now in the last
few minutes, I just
want to tell you a
really lovely thing.
So it should be pretty
clear at this point
that all the information
about scattering
is contained in the S matrix and
its dependence on the energy.
If you know what the
incident amplitudes are,
you know what the
outgoing amplitudes are,
and that's cool because
you can measure this.
You can take a potential,
you can literally just
send in a beam of
particles, and you
can ask, how likely
are they to get out.
And more importantly, if I
build a wave packet, on average,
what's the time
delay or acceleration
of the transmitted wave packet?
And that way, I can
measure the phase as well.
I can measure both the
transmission probabilities
and the phases, or at least
the gradient of the phase
with energy.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a special condition
that we can [? pose ?]
to see the resonance?
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
Hold onto your
question for a second.
There's an enormous amount
of the physics of scattering
contained in the S matrix, and
you can measure the S matrix,
and you can measure its
dependence on the energy.
You can measure the coefficients
S12 and S22, their phases
and their amplitudes,
as a function of energy,
and you can plot them.
Here's what I want
to convince you of.
If you plot those and look
at how the functions behave
as functions of energy and ask,
how do those functions extend
to negative energy by
just drawing the line,
continuing the lines,
you can derive the energy
of any bound states
in the system, too.
Knowledge of the scattering is
enough to determine the bound
state energies of a system,
and let me show you that.
And this is one of the coolest
things in quantum mechanics.
Here's how this works.
We have, from the
definition of the S matrix,
that BC is equal to
the S matrix on AD,
where the wave
function-- let me just
put this back in the original
form-- is CD, AB, e to the ikx,
e to the minus ikx, and e to the
plus ikx, e to the minus ikx.
So that's the definition
of the S matrix.
The S matrix, at
a given energy e,
is a coefficient relation
matrix between the ingoing
and outgoing, or, more
to the point, A and D.
And in all of this, I've assumed
that the energy was positive,
that the k1 and k2
are positive and real.
But now let's ask
the question, what
would have happened if,
in the whole process,
I had taken the
energy less than 0?
If the energy were less
than 0, instead of k,
k would be replaced by i alpha.
Let's think about
what that does.
If k is i alpha, this is
e to the ik is minus alpha
and minus ik is plus alpha.
Similarly, ik times i,
that gives me a minus alpha
and this gives me a plus alpha.
Yeah?
So as equations, they're
the same equations
with k replaced by i alpha.
And now what must be
true for these states
to be normalizable?
What must be true,
for example, of A?
A must be 0 because at minus
infinity, there's divergence.
Not normalizable.
So in order to be
at bound state,
in order to have a physical
state, A must be 0.
What about D?
Same reason.
It's got to be 0 at
positive infinity.
These guys are convergent,
so C and B can be non-zero.
So now here's my question.
We know that these
relations must be true
because all these relations are
encoding is how a solution here
matches to a solution
here through a potential
in between with continuity of
the derivative and anything
else that's true of
that potential inside.
All that S is doing
from that point of view
is telling me how
these coefficients
match onto these coefficients.
Yes?
Now what, for a bound state--
if we have e less than 0,
what must be true?
It must be true that AD is equal
to 0, and in particular, 00.
So what are B and C?
Well, a matrix times
0 is equal to--
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: Unless?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Unless the
matrix itself is diverging,
and then you have to be
more careful, but let's
be naive for the moment.
If A is 00, then in order
for B and C to be non-zero,
S must have a pole.
S must go like 1 over 0.
S must diverge at some
special value of the energy.
Well, that's easy.
That tells you that if you look
at any particular coefficient
in S, any of the
matrix elements of S,
the numerator can you whatever
you want, some finite number,
but the denominator
had better be?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
So let's look at
the denominator.
If I compute S21-- actually,
let me do this over here.
No, it's all filled.
Let's do it over here.
If I look at S21 for
the potential well,
scattering off
the potential well
that we looked at at the
beginning of today's lecture,
this guy, and now
I'm going to look
at S21, one of the
coefficients of this guy,
also known as the scattering
amplitude t for the well.
This is equal to-- and it's a
godawful expression-- 2 k1 k2
e to the i k2 L over
2 k1 k2 cos of k
prime L minus i k squared plus
k1 squared plus k2 squared
times sine of k2 L. This
is some horrible thing.
But now I ask the condition,
when does this have a pole?
When the energy has
continued to be negative,
for what values does
this have a pole
or does the
denominator have a 0?
And the answer is
if you take this
and you massage
the equation, this
is equal to 0 a little bit, you
get the following expression,
k2 L upon 2 tangent of k2 L
upon 2 is equal to k1 L upon 2.
This is the condition
for the bound state
energies of the
square well, and we
computed it using knowledge
only of the scattering states.
If you took particles
and a square well
and roll the particles across
the square well potential
and measure it as a function
of energy, the scattering
amplitude, the
transmission amplitude,
and in particular S21, an
element of the S matrix,
and you plotted it as
a function of energy,
and then you approximated that
by a function of energy that
satisfies the basic properties
of unitarity, what you would
find is that when
you then extend
that function in
mathematica to minus
a particular value
of the energy,
the denominator
diverges at that energy.
You know that there
will be a bound state.
And so from scattering,
you've determined
the existence of a bound state.
This is how we find an awful
lot of the particles that we
actually deduce must
exist in the real world.
We'll pick up next time.
[APPLAUSE]